how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about everything
Marvel and all things relating to the
MCU
I want to thank Skillshare for
sponsoring this video more on them in a
bit but first and foremost we have to
talk about mutants in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe probably one of the
most highly anticipated things right now
the mutants entering the MCU ever since
Kevin Feige mentioned them at San Diego
comic-con in 2019 everybody has been
wondering when exactly are we going to
see them and surprisingly based off of
everything that we've heard they're
going to start to show up in phase four
and not just in one movie but several
different movies and several different
projects as well and today we have a
report that says a certain mutant who is
heavily associated with spider-man is
going to be entering the MCU now based
off of everything that we've heard there
are going to be multiple mutants
introduced at different times in
Marvel's phase four however named so far
have only been rumored like the rumor
that Omega Red is going to make his
debut in shang-chi but today we have an
actual report so we'll break it all down
but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things MCU and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
black widow Funko pop all you got to do
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment down below today we have a leak
that says a fire star is going to be
coming to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
most likely in phase four fire star was
featured in spider-man and his amazing
friends she is Angelica Jones and is a
mutant but according to Daniel Richmond
would fall under Marvel Studios aside of
the MCU and not sony's spu MC Sony
Pictures universe of Marvel characters
but what's interesting is that this
report does not go on to say whether or
not she's going to debut in a movie or
in a Disney Plus show one of the really
interesting things about Firestar is
that her introduction to the Marvel
Universe was not in a comic book it was
actually in the TV show spider-man and
his amazing friends at number one she
would eventually go on to properly join
the Marvel Universe as a mutant in 1985
s uncanny x-men number 193 but she's
always had a very particular connection
to spider-man and the x-men
so her purpose and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe could be a bridge between the
Avenger characters like spider-man black
panther
strange and the x-men who are going to
be coming to the MCU as well and it
might actually be done in an entirely
new Disney Plus show you see in the
comics Firestar was a founding member of
the New Warriors and what's interesting
is that a while ago Marvel television
actually produced a pilot for a new
warrior series but it was never picked
up but they did have plans for those
characters of the new warriors including
Firestar
while Kevin Feige was never over Marvel
television at that time but now he is so
this may be getting picked back up again
and this could come as a Disney Plus
series or they could be introduced one
by one to eventually form the New
Warriors being in other movies in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as time goes
by but again she has a very big
connection to spider-man which means
that there is a possibility that she
could show up in spider-man 3 as I
mentioned a theory before in the past it
would make sense that if Peter is on the
run he would need some allies and would
need a place to go well perhaps some
mutants will enter at this place and
time in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and help Peter Parker out he could even
go on to hide out at Professor Xavier
school for gifted youngsters there are
rumors that Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness is going to form
the Illuminati and Professor X as a part
of the Illuminati in the comics so
Doctor Strange could know Professor
Xavier and if Peter Parker goes to
Doctor Strange for help he could point
him to Professor X that would give him
the help that he would need not to
mention it would help him develop his
skills as spider-man and this could
possibly be where he meets Firestar and
the new warriors now of course there is
a possibility again that the new
warriors could get their own television
show
but as Kevin Feige mentioned all Disney
Plus shows are a part of the MCU so
you're going to have to watch the Disney
Plus shows to know what's going on in
the movies but based off of this report
fire stars come into the MCU and it
sounds like we're going to be getting
her in phase four so if you've been
waiting for the mutants they are coming
very very soon and again I want to thank
Skillshare for sponsoring this video and
helping me pass the time during
quarantine I know a lot of you have been
asking me about YouTube how to get
started what editing software to use how
to use things like Photoshop and iMovie
well if you're looking for a place to
learn all of those things and expand
your creativity Skillshare is the place
for you and the great news is is that
the first thousand of my subscribers to
click the link in the description will
get a two month free trial of premium
membership so you can explore your
creativity if you're interested in
YouTube you could check out classes by
the teacher Sorrell amore who's got
great insight on what you need during
this time of quarantine I fought boredom
off by trying to get better at guitar by
taking classes on Skillshare so for
those of you who love to learn be sure
to click the link in the description
down below and if you're not one of the
first thousand people to click the link
the description down below
don't worry Skillshare is less than $10
a month with an annual subscription just
click the link down below to get started
so be sure to let me know your thoughts
about firestar and the new warriors
joining the MCU in the comments section
down below would you like to see them
introduced in other MCU films or would
you like to see them get their own TV
show let me know and don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU for live updates you can
follow me on Twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof